[Music]
when the helicopter rescue team arrived
at the outlet pass in february 1959 the
nine missing hikers had been dead for
weeks the more the investigators tried
to piece together what happened the more
the story didn't seem to add up their
tent had been cut open from the inside
and abandoned but there was no sign of a
struggle
over a half mile away two victims were
almost completely naked though
temperatures were 30 below zero that
night other bodies were found even
farther away two had fractured skulls
two more had major chest injuries one
was missing his eyes and another was
missing her tongue
and reports show that two of the hikers
had been exposed to unusually high
amounts of radiation soviet
investigators listed the cause of death
as a compelling natural force and closed
the case a few weeks later the diatlov
pass incident has been a mystery for
over 60 years and theories include a
military cover-up a kgb operation gone
wrong a bigfoot attack and of course
aliens now one researcher believes he
knows what happened that night
others are not so sure
let's find out why
[Music]
in the winter of 1959 nine russian
adventurers were on a 200-mile
cross-country hiking expedition making
their way through the siberian
wilderness this was difficult terrain
but the seven men and two women were
young fit and highly experienced skiers
and mountain climbers they were led by
23 year old igor diatlov a promising
student studying engineering at the euro
polytechnic institute a few others in
the group were classmates of his at upi
now before he left the otloff told his
friends back home that he would send
them a telegram as soon as the team
returned well that letter was never sent
and none of the group was ever seen
alive again the hikers documented
everything they kept journals and they
took tons of pictures they took selfies
tons of them now sure there was lots of
snow and frigid temperatures but
everyone was in good spirits and things
seemed to be going predictably until
february 1st that day the group was
making its way through the outlet pass
though back then it didn't have a name
and as they tried to push through they
were hit with high winds and snow the
decreasing visibility pushed the group
off course and they accidentally ended
up on the side of a mountain called
collatziaco by the region's indigenous
people cola cuculats collatiaco right we
got a translation
dead mountain oh boy this is a photo of
the group in deep snow with almost zero
visibility digging out a platform for
their tent
this is the last photo of them alive the
final entry in the group's diary reads
it is difficult to imagine such a
comfort on the ridge with shrill howling
wind hundreds of kilometers away from
human settlements and then
nothing
during their journey members of the
group sent postcards and letters to
family and friends informing them of
their progress but weeks had gone by
without a single word so people began to
worry on february 26th almost a month
later a search party was finally able to
locate the campsite and when they did it
was obvious something had gone terribly
wrong
the tent where the entire group slept
was discovered under a thin layer of
snow it had been cut open from the
inside but there was no sign of a
struggle food clothes gear were still
neatly stacked inside the tent a meal
had been set up but the food was
untouched and there were no bodies
the next day nine sets of footprints
were found leading down the mountain
into the woods the tracks were evenly
spaced and they weren't deep and this
told investigators that the group was
moving calmly and orderly they weren't
scrambling they weren't running and they
weren't fighting
but the tracks were odd they weren't
made with boots the tracks were made by
people wearing socks or barefoot in
sub-zero temperatures
searchers then came across a cedar tree
where they found the remains of a
campfire and near the fire buried in the
snow were the first two victims of the
outlook pass
durashenko and kravanashenko they were
almost naked wearing only underwear
though temperatures were 30 degrees
below zero that night pravana shanko had
blackened fingers and third-degree burns
on his shins and feet and for some
reason in his mouth was a chunk of flesh
that he had bitten off his right hand
the tree limbs above the fire were
broken over five meters above the ground
and pieces of flesh were found in the
tree bark and scraps of clothing were
found in the branches now why would they
climb a tree was visibility so poor that
they were looking for a way back to the
tent were they gathering wood for the
fire or were they trying to get away
from something
rescuers expanded the search area and
about 200 feet away they found three
more bodies including igor diatlov they
were positioned as if they were running
away from the tree trying to get back to
the tent investigators said all of them
had died of hypothermia as they had no
damage except for superficial injuries
and what would be caused by exposure to
cold but this doesn't explain why
duroshenko who was found under the tree
had skin that was brownish purple or why
he had gray foam and gray liquid coming
out of his mouth
it didn't explain the burns the flayed
limbs or why someone would bite off a
chunk of their own hand the second set
of bodies was also confusing one of them
had multiple skull fractures consistent
with falling and tumbling over and over
again but there were no bloody rocks or
stumps or any evidence anywhere that a
fall had occurred the only explanation
at this point that despite being highly
experienced at outdoor winter survival
they had suddenly fled into the dark and
the cold without adequate preparation
and were frantically trying to make do
before succumbing to the elements that's
only five what well it's only five out
of nine hikers did they finally had a
four they did but not until months later
and when those bodies were discovered
the story gets
even stranger
[Music]
four bodies were still missing for
months but in may when the snow began to
melt a local hunter found a makeshift
snow den in the woods about 250 feet
from the cedar tree a deep hole was cut
in the snow and the floor was made of
branches pieces of clothing were found
scattered around the den black sweat
pants with the right leg cut off the
left half of a woman's sweater another
search team arrived and they uncovered
the four remaining victims lying
together in at least 10 feet of snow
autopsy reports say that these people
died not of exposure but of massive
injuries and at this point criminal
investigators were brought in to
determine if there was foul play three
of the bodies had severe injuries
crushed body cavities broken ribs and
internal hemorrhaging one had a skull
fracture so severe the foul play was
eliminated because no human could
generate the kind of force to create
this level of damage instead the
injuries were consistent with being in a
car crash or near the explosion of a
bomb
but no soft tissue damage was found and
no external injuries a careful inventory
of clothing recovered showed that some
of the victims were wearing clothes
taken or cut off the bodies of the
others that died before them yeah
village well that's what they originally
thought but an avalanche would have
flattened the whole campsite but if you
look at the photos of the tent the
searchers found you can see that the
skis and ski poles are still upright
there was no damage to the tree line and
there was no debris and people who died
of avalanches usually asphyxiate but
post-mortem analysis shows no sign of
this they either died from injuries or
died of cold but either way when they
died they were still breathing the
locals say that the outlet pass doesn't
get avalanches none were reported before
the incident and none have been reported
since and what's even more strange is
two of the hikers eyes were missing and
one of them was missing her tongue
avalanches don't do that they don't
and maybe the strangest detail of all
two of the hikers clothing had
significant levels of radiation they
were radioactive yep now despite all the
strange evidence the case went nowhere
due to what was called an absence of a
guilty party the investigation was
closed a few weeks later the final
conclusion was that the cause of death
was an unknown compelling force which
the hikers were unable to overcome and
that was it that was it but the victims
families weren't satisfied so they
started demanding answers from the
soviet government how did the soviets
respond well all files journals and
photographs were classified the area was
made off limits and all evidence
collected was destroyed of course but
there's no shortage of theories about
what happened
can we we can
theories about what happened at the dial
of pass there are some good ones i'll
cover a few but i'll link to the full
list in the description the first theory
is
be patient sorry sorry go go ahead
remember that a lot of the hikers were
students at the euro polytechnic
institute or connected with upi in some
way
well upi was constantly turning out
recruits for nuclear research and the
soviet military oh i like where this is
going first theory the kgb connection
alexei ratikin wrote a book called the
outlook pass where he claimed that three
of the hikers were kgb agents on a
mission to uncover a secret cell of cia
operatives during the cold war a
favorite soviet tactic was to plant
radioactive material in places it didn't
belong just to set the americans on
fruitless searches now ratikin says that
two or three of the hikers were hired by
the kgb to deliver radioactive tainted
clothing to cia agents and the oldest
member of the group at age 37 semyon
zolotaryov joined the group at the last
minute he was a combat veteran with
years of military service who eventually
went to work for the nkvd or the soviet
secret police and before transferring to
the physics department at upi he worked
in moscow at a top secret scientific
facility known as p.o box 3394 and yuri
krivanashenko worked at p.o box 404
10 where a massive nuclear accident
occurred in 1957. alexi radican is
convinced that this group was not
gathered by accident the histories of at
least three of the hikers show a lot of
kgb connection the true objective of
their mission unknown to the other
members was to deliver radioactive
samples to a group of agents of the cia
and take pictures of the spies at the
beginning of the journey all the hikers
had cameras and journals we saw them but
when kolevotov's body was discovered his
journal and camera were missing and he
was one of the suspected spies
now theory number two like who's this
guy
[Music]
in 2014 the discovery channel released a
documentary called russian yeti the
killer lives and they used the diatlov
incident to make their case that the
hikers had disturbed the natural habitat
of a yeti and they used this photo as
evidence that the doc went on to say
that the yeti was the reason the bodies
were missing eyes and a tongue now this
photo has been authenticated it's
absolutely real but it doesn't look much
like a bigfoot to me and that
documentary was
well it was garbage so next theory
aliens
ball lightning close enough this theory
says that the reason for the tent being
cut from the inside was not to escape
but to set up a camera on a makeshift
tripod the otlef himself had
experimented with telescopes and was
interested in space flight and astronomy
the local nancy people had reported
seeing glowing golden orbs in the sky
that same night and another hiking group
camping 50 kilometers away also reported
orange floating orbs in the exact same
place at the exact same time there even
recovered photos from one of the cameras
that shows some type of lights in the
sky lev ivanov the lead investigator of
the incident said i suspected at the
time and am almost sure now that these
bright flying spheres had a direct
connection to the group's death he also
reported that the treetops in the area
were burned above a certain height in
1990 after ivanov retired he published
an article claiming that the soviet
government forced him to abandon this
theory and they removed everything from
the report that mentioned ufos orbs or
anything unusual he insisted the deaths
were due to heat rays or balls of fire
associated with orbs yes
another scientific theory is that a rare
weather event generated infrasound that
caused the hikers to suddenly become
disoriented and anxious donnie eicher
who spent five years researching the
incident and actually visited the site
believes that a wind phenomenon called a
carmen vortex street could have produced
a terrifying powerful sound which has
proven to induce irrational fear in
humans we have a video about this on the
channel i'll link below a nice plug now
if hit with infrasound the group might
have fled the tent and fallen victim to
the cold before they realized what was
happening now those are just a few of
the theories that have been circulating
for years some say a weapons test went
wrong others say the military killed the
group and staged the scene carbon
monoxide poisoning is another theory or
a bad mushroom trip though toxicology
reports discount those
reports theories you believe the reports
nobody has been able to come up with a
definitive answer that is until this
year two scientists think they've solved
the mystery of the outlook pass and they
use the movie frozen to prove their
theory did you just say they use frozen
yeah the disney movie that's right let
it go
let it go
[Music]
that one yeah that that one no this i
got it here
though the avalanche theory has been
mostly dismissed a new theory has been
proposed that the hikers were hit by a
very specific and rare kind of avalanche
johann gome a scientist who studies snow
phenomena was watching the movie frozen
that disney had created very realistic
snow movement so he worked with studio
animators to develop a model that shows
how the group could have been hit by
what's called a delayed slab avalanche
this kind of avalanche occurs when you
affect the warm wet snow at the bottom
of a slope this causes the entire face
of snow to eventually move at once now
think about when you have two books
stacked on top of each other you could
tilt them and they'll stick together
until you reach a certain angle
top book slides now an avalanche only
requires a 20 degree slope to trigger it
now the otlov camp was built at 23
degrees gom believes that when they cut
into the snow to build their tent it
started a countdown they initiated a
chain reaction of micro disturbances
that took a few hours to propagate
trapped under the slab the group might
have panicked and cut their way out the
injuries sustained by some of the group
would have been consistent with another
slab hitting them at full force yeah but
what about all the you know
well gom says we say that this is
possible that such a slab avalanche
would have injured them the way they
were
everything that happened after the
avalanche is out of the scope of our
paper
though it wasn't snowing that night the
hikers did have journal entries about
howling winds these were most likely
katabatic winds and katabatic winds fall
down a slope and quickly gain speed due
to gravity and the winds are hurricane
force and they were absolutely detected
by local weather stations that night so
the hikers cut their camp into the snow
which disturbed the slab then katabatic
winds started blowing snow on top of the
slab above the tent and over the course
of hours the weight of the snow above
camp reached critical mass causing the
entire slab to fall now using the disney
snow animation it was shown that just a
small avalanche maybe five by five
meters would have been enough to cover
the camp but not enough snow that the
rescue team would have noticed
especially since they didn't arrive on
scene for 26 more days so given this new
information can we piece together what
happened to diatlov and his friends that
night
i think we can
[Music]
kgb ufos orbs of light these are fun
theories but i think this is what
happened the slab avalanche hits
covering them in a few feet of snow the
nine campers cut their way out of the
tent
what
why leave all this stuff in the tent and
then go out in the cold in his stevies
well it was discovered that they had a
second stash of supplies in the forest
so they escaped the avalanche knowing
they have backup supplies they retreat
to the trees and start a fire the young
trees at the bottom of the slope were
icy and wet so they climbed the cedar in
search of dry wood but with temperatures
30 below zero they had very little time
to save themselves the two most poorly
dressed were probably the first to go
the burn skin probably from being
desperately close to the fire and with
hypothermia setting in they were losing
sensation and didn't realize they were
being burned kravenoshenko losing
feeling and probably becoming delirious
bites his hand to test for sensation and
he dies within an hour seven survivors
cut the clothes away from their friends
and dress themselves in whatever they
can scavenge from the bodies three of
the group including diatlov try to make
it back to the tent but the steep
incline and loose snow make it a
difficult task they soon freeze to death
in the struggle uphill the remaining
four decide to build a snow shelter for
the night they find deep snow in a
ravine a couple hundred feet away but
their bad luck continues and they pick a
spot near a fast running stream that
never freezes the stream cuts away the
snow above their shelter causing the
roof to collapse they're thrown onto the
rocky stream bed and buried under 10 or
15 feet of snow now in general snow
weighs about 20 pounds per cubic foot a
little over a pound per inch of depth a
section of snow that's 20 feet by 20
feet with a depth of 10 feet that weighs
between 85 000 and 100 000 pounds that's
50 tons falling on you so it's like
being crushed under a tank so your
injuries would be severe
the missing eyes and tongue probably
caused by scavenging animals or just by
three months of decomposition near
running water what about the radiation
right the lanterns they used which were
found at the site contain small amounts
of thorium which is radioactive and
remember at least two of the hikers
worked at a nuclear facility and helped
with cleanup after an accident that was
almost as bad as chernobyl so
in retrospect the nine campers made only
one mistake the placement of the tent
everything else was by the book they
conducted an orderly evacuation to stay
for ground they took shelter in the
woods started a fire and dug out a snow
cave the textbook wrong decision in an
avalanche is to stay put unfortunately
that wrong decision might have saved
their lives
[Music]
now today diatlov pass is a popular
tourist destination people come from all
over the world to follow the group's
footsteps and see where the tent once
stood
people say prayers at the stream and
leave flowers under the cedar tree where
its broken branches are still visible
and just before the team embarked on
their adventure kravenoshenko wrote a
poem addressing the entire group here's
wishing you camps pitched on mount zafar
routes to hike over range is untamed
packs that as ever rest lightly on your
backs
and whether that smiles upon your quest
and let your footprints trace winding
tracks across the map
of russia
it's been over 60 years since the
outlook and eight of his courageous
friends died on dead mountain but i'm
sure they'd be proud to know that not
only did they leave their footprints on
the map of russia but on the map of the
entire world
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything today do me a favor
and like subscribe comment and share
those little favors really help out the
channel until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
[Applause]
you